candidates senator david perdue joins us
now senator thanks very much for joining
us i know you're
a busy man and i think what we what
we're seeing here
and i think as hillary also found out is
that celebrity doesn't necessarily
matter so much and neither does having
the most money
it's about reminding people about what's
at stake and how donald trump won and
why he won which was about on the issues
and and wanting to maintain what has
already been accomplished
tell us how you're viewing this in the
midst of a very unique situation and
what your thoughts are with the upcoming
election
well hi tammy thanks for having me but
you know we already won this race once
in november
we beat the democratic candidate by two
points and the libertarian got two so
the reality is that fifty two and a half
percent of georgians
voted against this democratic agenda
that's been perpet
they're trying to perpetrate on america
and they defeated john ossoff so
at 47.5 they've got a long way to go but
we're not taking anything for granted
we're out doing a 125
stop bus tour right now kelly leftward
is doing the same thing
and we're taking it to the people in
small town georgia to make sure they
understand what's at stake
and they have a responsibility to get
out and vote if we get our vote out
i'll be very pleased with the outcome
but we're not taking anything for
granted tammy
well that's good news because obviously
there is a concern about
you know we want legal votes to be
counted uh we want all the we want
more people to vote the better because
americans have a tendency to not vote on
mass
so this is a a good thing for people to
go out and vote
but there's been some discussion about
the feud between president trump
and governor kemp of georgia who many
people feel has not done enough
to make people feel that there's enough
control over this this runoff
some people want him primaried are you
do you think that is having an impact
on the republican party itself because
this clearly this race
uh transcends party politics this is
about individual personal freedom
right uh and that means the the trump
agenda being maintained and you've got
to do that by
keeping the senate uh is it impacting
your race and
um how does it feel on the ground right
now in the midst of all of that
tammy momentum is coming our way people
realize what's at stake here
we're the last line of defense against
the democratic onslaught
and this radical socialist agenda that
they've aspired to in the presidential
election and continue to do so now
people in georgia are beginning to
realize how serious this is and we won't
get another chance if we don't stop it
now
but the other thing is what you just
said if we gain these two seats and hold
these two seats in the republican hands
we can block
what these democrats are trying to do
and protect what president trump has
accomplished over the last four years
energy independence the iran nuclear
deal we helped six and a half million
people pull themselves out of poverty
because of this economic turnaround
these are things that the american
people really want i get
emails and texts every day please hold
the line in georgia and that's what
we're committed to do here
well and that's imperative obviously
because everyone
no matter what your party we've enjoyed
being able to have our jobs back we've
enjoyed
the extraordinary economy that we've
accomplished the idea of peace in the
middle east being accomplished so that
your loved ones don't have to be sent to
a foreign country
to never come home again for african
americans the
the the wage gap shrinking no one wants
that lost
and this is what's at stake here now
rafael warnock uh however is now also
dodging questions about
this body cam footage sir that surfaced
of his ex-wife let's take a listen
this man's running for the united states
senate and all he cares about right now
is his reputation i work at the mayor's
office
and this is a big problem i've been
trying to be very quiet about the way
that he is for the sake of my kids and
his reputation
i've tried to keep the way that he acts
under wraps for a long time
and today he crossed the line
so that is what is going on here and
he's a great actor he is phenomenal
at putting on a really good show now
that's uh
one accusation obviously against one
individual but when we talk about
economic security
is allowing women and everyone in every
dynamic to be able to choose
lives that best suit them with security
and their freedom
senator warnock said he was staying
focused on his family and the people of
georgia
but do you think people deserve a bit
more of an explanation here about what
she was talking about and what this
means about his character
of course we do the more we learn about
raphael warnock and john ossoff the more
questions haven't been answered i mean
for example
john ossoff has this huge china scandal
that he's not come clean on yet
and it really makes eric swallow and
hunter biden's situation
small in comparison this is a man that
i'm running against that took money from
the chinese communist party for two
years
hid it lied about it got caught then
came clean and lied about it again
so we've got a lot of questions that
people in georgia are asking about this
rafael warnock
has said not only wants to defund the
police he calls them
thugs criminals i mean these are people
that the bench on the democratic side
if these are the two types of people
they want to represent georgia
they're out of step with most georgians
these are the most liberal candidates
that i can remember in my lifetime the
democrats putting up from any state
and the people of georgia beginning to
realize that tammy i would hope so
georgia's great state senator thank you
very much look this again
transcends uh party politics this is
about
the american future uh and this is one
issue we can do do these projects one at
a time
for people who have a problem with what
certain republicans are doing
that can be addressed later on but keep
our eye on the prize here thank you sir
for joining me i appreciate it now